THEY'RE THE MVP ODDS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE AT THE POINTS.
BET SPORTS BOOK PETRA HOME.
STILL THE FAVORITE AT PLUS
450, AARON RODGERS,
PLUS, 900 HARD TO WIN IT, IF
YOU OPT OUT FOR THE
2020, ONE SEASON AND THEN
EVERYONE ELSE IN FOUR DIGITS
WITH JOSH ALLEN AND TOM,
BRADY EACH @, +
1300 BIG HEAD. WHO WOULD
YOU
BASED ON THOSE
ODDS? WHO WOULD YOU WAGER ON
FOR MVP? DO YOU GO WITH THE
CHALK OR DO YOU TRY TO FIND
SOMEBODY WHO'S, WHO'S KIND OF
FLOATING,
YOU KNOW, IN
A SPOT WHERE IT'S GOING TO PAY
OFF A LITTLE BIT MORE FOR YOU.
I KIND OF LIKE THAT MATT
STAFFORD
WAS LIKE 18 TO 1 BECAUSE YOU
KNOW HE
WHEN IT COMES TO MVP IT'S
OBVIOUSLY PLAY BUT IT'S
STORYLINE AS WELL. WE SAW IT
LAST YEAR WITH RUSSELL WILSON
THIS SEASON STARTED, HE WAS
PHENOMENAL TO START SEASON.
ANY HAD THE STORYLINE THAT
FACT THAT HE HAD NEVER BEEN
VOTED DOWN A SINGLE VOTE FOR
MVP,
KIND OF SWEPT THE NATION.
HE WASN'T ABLE TO SUSTAIN HIS
PLAY, BUT IF HE HAD BEEN
EVEN LIKE
ABLE TO SUSTAIN IT TO
90% OR 80% OF WHAT HE WAS
DOING TO START THE SEASON. HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE RUNAWAY
MVP, SO
MATT STAFFORD DEFINITELY IS A
STORYLINE GUY LIKE IF HE
STARTS OUT HOT THERE'S GOING
TO BE PIECES WRITTEN ABOUT HIM
FOR ABOUT MATT STAFFORD ABOUT
HIS TIME. IN DETROIT ABOUT HIS
SWITCH TO LA AND YOU KNOW,
HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH SEAN
MCVEIGH, I CAN SEE IT RIGHT
NOW.
PULL UP THE SCHEDULE WHENEVER
THE RAMS PLAY, YOU KNOW,
MONDAY NIGHT, FOOTBALL
WEEK NINE,
9, I'M JUST
SITTING RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE SEASON,
IF THERE ARE SIX
INTO GOING INTO THAT GAME,
MATT STAFFORD WILL HAVE THE
HEIGHT. MATT STAFFORD WILL
START GETTING THE LOVE THAT HE
PROBABLY DESERVES YOUR. HE'S
BEEN A VERY GOOD QUARTERBACK
FOR A VERY LONG TIME. THE
NFL
HERE'S HOW I LOOK AT THE MVP
AWARD AND I FEEL THIS
WAY EVERY YEAR, UNLESS THERE'S
SOMEONE WHO DOES SOMETHING
THAT
IT SETS AN ALL-TIME RECORD OR
COMES CLOSE TO IT LIKE ADRIAN
PETERSON IN 2012 WHEN HE
ALMOST SET THE SINGLE-SEASON
RUSHING RECORD,
TYPICALLY IT'S THE QUARTERBACK
OF ONE OF THE TEAMS THAT
FINISHES WITH A BY AND NOW
THAT THERE'S ONLY
ONE BY / CONFERENCE
AVAILABLE. YOU GOT TO BE THE
QUARTERBACK
OF THE
1 SEED LIKE
AARON RODGERS. LAST YEAR,
QUARTERBACK OF THE ONE SEED
IN THE NFC
OR
QUARTERBACK OF THE ONE SEED IN
THE AFC AND
IT'S WHICHEVER OF THOSE TWO
GUYS,
THE QUARTERBACKS AT THE
TO NUMBER ONE SEEDS, WHO HAD
THE BETTER STATISTICAL YEAR
WHEN THE DUST SETTLES, THAT'S
WHAT IT IS. AND IT COULD BE
MATTHEW STAFFORD, THE RAMS
COULD END UP BEING THE ONE
SEED IN THE NFC. NOW, I DON'T
LIKE THEIR CHANCES WHEN YOU'VE
GOT THE 49ERS SEAHAWKS AND
CARDINALS IN YOUR DIVISION,
BUT, BUT STAFFORD FITS
THE PROFILE. IF THE
RAMS TRULY ARE REJUVENATED AND
AND I MEAN, LOOK AT HOW THEY
DID.
DID LAST YEAR WITH YOUR
FRIEND JARED GOFF YOU,
YOU UPGRADE TO MATTHEW
STAFFORD. I THINK YOU'RE, I
THINK YOU'RE KIND OF
INDIRECTLY THROWING SHADE
OF JARED GOFF
BY PUTTING MATTHEW STAFFORD IN
THE MVP CONVERSATION.
I DON'T SEE I DON'T SEE GOLF
ON THE LIST OF ODDS ANYWHERE,
BUT BUT IF THE RAMS
ARE THE
ONE SEED, STAFFORD'S THE MVP
UNLESS PATRICK MAHOMES
HAS A BETTER YEAR
AND HAS THAT STORY. YOU'RE
RIGHT. THE NARRATIVE STARTS
SEPTEMBER,
OCTOBER
IS
AND THEN THE QUESTION IS, CAN
YOU CARRY IT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH? AND ONCE YOU CATCH
THAT WAVE, IT'S LIKE A SURFER
ONE BECAUSE AARON RODGERS
EVENTUALLY CAUGHT THE WAVE IN
NOVEMBER AND RODE IT ALL THE
WAY TO THE END OF THE SEASON.
YOU GET DIFFERENT CHANCES TO
CATCH THAT WAVE. AND THEN THE
QUESTION IS, HOW LONG CAN YOU
RIDE IT?
AND THE GUY WHO CATCHES IT IN
NOVEMBER DECEMBER AND RIDES IT
OUT TO THE FINISH IS THE GUY
WHO GETS IT, IT'S USUALLY A
QUARTERBACK FROM ONE OF THE
ONE SEATS. YEAH, RUSSELL
WILSON. IF HE HAD JUST RODE
THAT WAVE A LITTLE BIT LONGER,
HE WOULD HAVE HAD A LEGITIMATE
CHANCE.
SO I
YEAH, I MEAN MATT STAFFORD.
YOU CAN SEE IT HAPPENING
ALREADY TO THAT STORY, THAT
CAME OUT WITH SHAWN, MCVEIGH
WAS TALKING GLOWINGLY ABOUT
MATT STAFFORD. I THINK THAT
THAT'S GOING TO BE A STORY.
THAT A LOT OF JOURNALISTS, A
LOT OF THE MEDIA WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT THIS GUY WHO
HAS HAD ALL THE STATISTICS
IN HIS ENTIRE CAREER.
GOING TO A PLACE WHERE YOU
HAVE SHA MCVEIGH A QUARTERBACK
GURU AND IT
LEGITIMATE CHANCE TO GO
DEEP IN THE PLAYOFFS
THAT PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE
FASCINATED BY THIS. ADD THE
THE LA
FACTOR
AND THE FASTER, THE LA HAS A
SUPER BOWL THIS YEAR,
I'M WRITING THE STORY FOR YOU.
MIKE,
THERE YOU GO. I JUST DID YOUR
JOB FOR YOU.
GIVE ME SOMEONE
OFF THE RADAR.
OUT OF NOWHERE.
WHO YOU THINK COULD EMERGE
AS THAT GUY WHO CATCHES A
WAVE AND AND RIDES THAT
WAVE ALL THE WAY THROUGH TO
THE END OF THE SEASON, IS THE
MVP.
WELL, HE'S NOT OUT OF NOWHERE
AND HE'S NOT OFF THE RADAR,
BUT I DO THINK JOSH ALLEN IS A
CANDIDATE FOR THAT BECAUSE YOU
SAW IT LAST YEAR AT THE
BILLS, BECAME A STORY THAT
PEOPLE WERE VERY ATTACHED TO
AND LOVE. SO IF JOSH
HOLLAN, CAN DUPLICATE WHAT HE
DID LAST YEAR,
AND HE WAS PHENOMENAL
LAST YEAR, I THINK THAT HE
WILL
THE
NARRATIVE IS NOW
THEY'RE LIKE LAST YEAR, JOSH
ALAN
ARRIVED,
QUOTE, UNQUOTE
TO EVERYONE KIND OF COMING TO
GRIPS WITH THE FACT THAT HEY
MAYBE PEOPLE WERE WRONG ABOUT
THEIR DRAFT ANALYSIS, MAYBE
THIS GUY CAN BE REALLY, REALLY
GOOD FOR A LONG TIME,
EVEN THOUGH I LOVED HIM AND I
LOVE HIM AND HE'S MY BEST
FRIEND
BUT
THIS IS NOW THE SEASON WHERE
IF HE
DUPLICATES IT
IT'S LIKE OH OKAY WELL HE'S
GOING TO HAVE THAT
MVP TALK
WEEK ONE, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN? LIKE, IF
JOSH ALLEN COMES OUT.
OUT AND THROWS.
LET'S SAY.
10 10 TOUCHDOWN. LET'S SAY 11.
TOUCHDOWNS ONE INTERCEPTION IN
THE FIRST THREE WEEKS OF THE
SEASON
AND THE BILLS ARE THREE
AND ZERO. THERE WILL
ABSOLUTELY BE MVP TALK WITH
JOSH
HOWARD.
YEAH, BUT THEN HE'S GOT TO
CARRY IT OUT. HE'S GOT A RIDE,
IT OUT
AND APPEARED TO BETTER THIS
YEAR. HE'S GOT TO DEAL WITH
THE CHIEFS IN THE RAVENS BUT
AND WE TALKED ABOUT JOSH ALAN
YESTERDAY, WHAT'S IT GOING TO
TAKE FOR HIM TO GET TO THE
NEXT LEVEL? SIMS HASN'T NUMBER
TWO BEHIND PATRICK MAHOMES
CAN ALAN
NEVER OVERTAKE MAHOMES AND,
YOU KNOW, HE'S GOT TO BEAT MY
HOMES AND HE HAD A CHANCE LAST
YEAR, IN THE REGULAR SEASON.
HE WAS KIND OF FLAT, AND THEN
THEY HAD THE CHANCE IN THE AFC
CHAMPIONSHIP, AND HE DIDN'T
PULL IT OFF. BUT HE'S GOT
WEEK, FIVE
SUNDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL, AGAINST
THE CHIEFS. THAT COULD BE THE
COMING-OUT PARTY FOR THE JOSH
ALLEN MVP.
THAT'S NOT REALLY OFF THE
RADAR. HE'S ALL RIGHT, I GOT
ONE. I GOT IN YOU. I GOT
ANOTHER ONE. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
I GOT ANOTHER ONE. I DON'T
KNOW IF WE HAVE THIS.
BUT A CERTAIN FUTURE HALL OF
FAMER
WAS
DOING SOME TYPE OF
EXERCISE TRAINING SESSION.
WHERE HE WAS GETTING BEAT UP
IN THE POCKET AND COUNTING
OUT NUMBERS.
THAT'S THE ONE
AND ONLY JAMEIS WINSTON
I
SUGGEST THAT WE DO. I WAS
GONNA SAY YEAH THAT'S
WHAT I WAS GONNA SAY.
YOU DON'T HAVE DERANGEMENT
SYNDROME. THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR.
JAMEIS WINSTON
SIMILAR TO A
MATT STAFFORD AND THAT YOU GOT
THE QB
GURU, CIAO.
PEYTON'S THERE. CAN HE WORK
AROUND THE SYSTEM? HE'S GOT
GUYS TO THROW TO, HE'S GOT A
SYSTEM IN PLACE. HE LEARNED IT
LAST YEAR.
THE ST. STILL HAVE A VERY GOOD
ROSTER LIKE YOU KNOW,
COULD IT BE ONE OF THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE JAMEIS
WINSTON,
YOU KNOW,
IS BETTER THAN
HE'S BETTER THAN DREW BREES
LAST YEAR. SO EVERYONE SAYS,
OH WOW,
WILL DREW BREES. MAYBE WAS
REALLY INJURED LIKE I'VE BEEN
SAYING FOR A REALLY LONG TIME,
HEY BIG CAT WAS RIGHT
BUT JAMEIS WINSTON
WOULD BE A GOOD CANDIDATE
IN OUT OF NOWHERE.
NOWHERE, MVP
CANDIDATE.
FIRST, HE'S GOT TO WIN THE
STARTING JOB WHICH HE MAY NOT
DO, BUT IF HE DOES,
WE KNOW WHAT
YOU CAN DO
FROM YOUR KNOW WHAT
YOU PAY YOUR GLORIFIED TIGHT
END, YOUR LITTLE GADGET GUY.
WE KNOW WHAT SEAN PAYTON CAN
DO WITH A QUARTERBACK. WE
KNOW HOW HE GOES, ABOUT
CONSTRUCTING AN OFFENSE AND
GETTING THE MOST OUT OF THE
PLAYERS THAT HE HAS THE SAINTS
HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENTLY GOOD YEAR IN AND
YEAR OUT
AND WINSTON HAS A
FIVE THOUSAND YARD PASSING
SEASON AND THERE AREN'T MANY
GUYS IN THE HISTORY OF THE NFL
WHO HAVE
I'VE DONE THAT AND
I MADE THIS ARGUMENT TO PETER
KING ON A FRIDAY, SEVERAL
WEEKS AGO,
YOU LOOK AT WHO JAMEIS WINSTON
WAS COACHED BY HE HAD
DIRK CUTTER FOR THE FIRST
THREE OR FOUR YEARS WHO
CURRENTLY IS NOT THE NFL.
AND THEN HE HAD MR. NO RISK AT
NO BISCUIT. G THE YEAR HE
THREW 30
INTERCEPTIONS AND
5,000 YARDS AND
THIRTY FIVE TOUCHDOWN PASSES.
HIS COACH WAS NO RISK AT
NO BISCUIT, WHAT A SHOCK, HE
THREW 30 INTERCEPTIONS WHEN
YOU'RE HERE IN NO RISK AT NO
BISCUIT
EVERY SINGLE DAY OF THE
SEASON,
YOU PUT HIM WITH
PEYTON.
WHO'S GOING TO MAKE IT MORE
CAREFUL, AND DELIBERATE AND
STRATEGIC,
AND NOT NO RISK AT
NO BISCUIT.
I'M WITH YOU. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE JAMEIS WINSTON ODDS
ARE,
BUT
YOU COULD PROBABLY MAKE SOME
MONEY IF YOU'RE WILLING TO
DROP A HUNDRED OR SO ON
JAMEIS WINSTON, YOU'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE THAT
FLIP INTO SOMETHING BIG, IF HE
ENDS UP BEING THE GUY
DON'T FORGET TO THROW IN THE
FACT THAT HE JUST GOT LASIK.
HE CAN SEE NOW
HE WAS PLAYING QUARTERBACK
BLIND IN THE NFL, HE'S
ACTUALLY THE GREATEST BLIND.
AND QUARTERBACK OF ALL TIME.
I'M CONFIDENTLY, GOING TO SAY
THAT. SO JAMEIS
WINSTON WAS
EXCEPTIONAL
NUMBERS-WISE FOR HIS FIRST
FIVE YEARS OF HIS CAREER FOR
YEARS OF HIS CAREER
AND HE ACTUALLY COULDN'T SEE
HE COULDN'T SEE THE MIDDLE.
LINEBACKER, HE WENT
GOT
LAZY LASIK. HE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN WEARING GLASSES. THE
WHOLE TIME SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DOING THE REC SPECS. NOW HE
CAN SEE.
WATCH OUT WORLD
JAMEIS WINSTON, FUTURE HALL OF
FAMER.
62 1 ARE THE POINTS. BET ODDS
FOR
WATCHING THE SAME AS TO, UH,
SAME AS TO, UH, I WOULD GO
WINSTON OVER TO IN A
HEARTBEAT. I LOVE
TO BUT I GOT TO SEE IT FROM
TOOL BEFORE. I'M GOING TO
BELIEVE IN HELL. THERE'S A
CHANCE TO SHOW ON WATSON'S
GOING TO BE THE WEAK ONE
STARTER IN MIAMI. ANYWAY, THIS
YEAR,
WHERE'S THAT COMING FROM MIKE?
IS THERE ANOTHER
ANOTHER JUST THING YOU READ,
YEAH. HOW MANY DOCUMENTS DO
YOU GET THROUGH TO READ THAT
IF YOU TO GET TO THAT
CONCLUSION?
GO AHEAD AND SCOFF, GO AHEAD
AND SCOTT. I'M JUST ASKING,
WHERE'D IT COME FROM
EVERYWHERE? YEAH, I HEARD IT.
I'M JUST TELLING YOU, JUST
REMEMBER WHERE YOU HEARD IT.
IF IT HAPPENS, IT'S ALL I'M
SAYING. THERE'S NO THERE WERE
NO
HIGH-LEVEL DONE. IF IT DOESN'T
THE PRODUCT OF STAYING ON TOP
OF THE STORY EVERY SINGLE DAY
FOR THREE MONTHS, IF IT
DOESN'T, THEN WE JUST KEEP
MOVING. I'M NOT SAYING IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
I'M JUST SAYING THAT ONE OF
THE IMPEDIMENTS TO, TO A
WINNING MVP
IS
THE DOLPHINS. NOT ACQUIRING
DESHAUN WATSON. THAT'S ALL I'M
SAYING. THAT WOULD
OCCASIONALLY BE AN IMPEDIMENT
TO
TO A BEING THE MVP.
IF DETROIT WATSON IS THE
STARTER, I'LL JUST SAY
IT TO SEAN. WATSON COULD BE
THE WEAK ONE STARTED IN MIAMI
DOLPHINS. THERE, I ACTUALLY
THE FORTITUDE TO SAY THAT. SO
WHEN IT HAPPENS CREDIT ME,
THIS GUY
NOT MIKE FLORIO THIS
DEFENSIVE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
YEAH,
I KNOW. I'M NOT GOING TO SAY
IT.
OKAY, I'LL SAY IT. NO, I'M NOT
GONNA SAY IT BEST
ODDS OF FOR WINNING
OFFENSIVE. ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
TREVOR LAWRENCE IS
PLUS, 275
JUSTIN FIELDS,
+500 TRAIL, AND PLUS 700
SACK WILSON PLUS 800.
I KNOW I LIKE AND IT'S NONE OF
THOSE GUYS.
THOSE GUYS
IS NOT NOW
NOW, I DON'T KNOW HOW I FEEL
ABOUT NAUSEA HARRIS. AFTER
DAVID DE CASTRO GOT CUT BY THE
STEELERS YESTERDAY, BUT I'VE
BEEN SAYING NAUSEA HARRIS ALL
ALONG
IT, GOT, AND HE WEARS IT ON
THAT BOARD. WHERE'S KYLE
PITS?
OH,
40 BAGS. ONLY
QUARTERBACKS ONLY
OH GOT IT, GOT IT, GOT IT. ALL
RIGHT
BECAUSE YOU SAY KYLE PITS IS
GOING IS GOING TO WIN,
OFFENSIVE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
I JUST THROW THAT OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW. HE'S GOING TO WIN.
WOW, YEAH. THERE'S ANOTHER
WHILE I JUST THINK HE'S HE IS
READY TO GO RIGHT AWAY.
HE'S GOING TO CATCH A LOT OF
BALLS. HE'S GOING TO PUT UP
CRAZY
NUMBERS.
AND WE ALWAYS SEE IT LIKE THE,
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN HAVE THOSE
IMPACT ROOKIES AT RUNNING BACK
WIDE RECEIVER WHO COME IN AND
MAKE A BIG SPLASH RIGHT AWAY.
AND EVERYONE LIKE EVERYONE'S
LIKE, OH MY GOD, THIS GUY IS
INCREDIBLE. SO I
THINK
KYLE PUTS WOULD OFFENSIVE
ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR.
I DON'T THINK A TIGHT END IS
EVERYONE OFFENSIVE ROOKIE OF
THE YEAR? I DON'T THINK THAT'S
EVER HAPPENED. HE'S, HE'S
TEN TO ONE, TOO. PERFECT TO
WIN IT. AND WITH JULIO JONES,
NOT THERE,
GOTTA THROW THE FOOTBALL TO
SOMEBODY. I JUST THINK THAT
OFFENSIVE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
THE MORE YOU HAVE THE BALL IN
YOUR HANDS, THE BETTER, THE
CHANCE YOU HAVE TO WIN IT AND
I THINK OF YOU KNOW, RUNNING
BACK CAN GENERATE
STATS ROOKIE QUARTERBACK.
OBVIOUSLY THE RUNNING BACK
AND GENERATE STATS.
QUARTERBACKS GOT TO BE A WEEK.
ONE STARTER. HOW MANY OF THESE
GUYS GOING TO BE
WEAK ONE STARTERS? THAT'S A
PROBLEM JUST
IN FEELS. WE DON'T THINK HE'S
GONNA BE A WEEK. ONE STARTER,
DO YOU THINK HE'S GOING TO BE
THE WEAK ONE STARTER? I'M JUST
SAYING FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
OF HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RACK UP, THE KIND OF NUMBERS
THAT WILL GET YOU THE VOTES
NOW, LAST YEAR AT WORK FOR
JUSTIN
TO AND HE WAS GREAT AND JOE
BOROUGH GOT INJURED. BUT
OF THE QUARTERBACKS I WOULD
TEND TO THINK THAT
ZACK WILSON WOULD HAVE THE
BEST CHANCE JUST BECAUSE HE
WILL BE THE WEAK ONE STARTER.
AND IF HE IS AS GOOD
OR EVEN CLOSE TO, AS GOOD AS
SIMS SEEMS TO THINK HE IS. AND
FROM WHAT I'VE SEEN, HE DOES
HAVE SOME SPECIAL SKILLS,
YOU KNOW, THE NEW YORK MARKET.
YOU HELPED TURN A TEAM AROUND.
THAT'S BEEN BAD FOR SO LONG I
COULD SEE WILSON, BUILDING
SOME BUZZ, HE'S GOING TO HAVE
TO GET, YOU KNOW,
THREE, FOUR THOUSAND YARDS
PASSING, BUT
HE LOOKS LIKE A GUY WHO CAN DO
IT TO ME.
YEAH, I'D AGREE WITH YOU THERE
JUST BECAUSE WE YOU KNOW, IT'S
SIMILAR TO THE MVP
CONVERSATION, THE NARRATIVE
BEHIND IT. TREVOR LAWRENCE
IS ALREADY KIND OF EXPECTED TO
BE A FRANCHISE QUARTERBACK
FOREVER. SO HE
THE EXPECTATIONS FOR TREVOR.
LAWRENCE ARE A LITTLE UNFAIR,
RIGHT OUT OF THE GATE. SO
YOU KNOW, IF HE, IF THEY
HAD THE EXACT SAME NUMBERS,
THERE ROOKIE SEASON. EVERYONE
WILL LOOK AT ZACH WILSON'S
SEASON AS BEING BETTER THAN
TREVOR LAWRENCE, JUST BECAUSE
OF HOW WE FRAME
IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE TREVOR
LAWRENCE. DO YOU LIKE IT OR
YOU DON'T? OR DO YOU NOT LIKE
THE FACT THAT NO
ONE REALLY?
IS PAYING ATTENTION
TO TREVOR LAWRENCE AT ALL?
IT'S ALL JUSTIN FIELDS AND
WENT TO MY AUNT'S.
WELL AND THEN YOU THROW TIM
TEBOW ON TOP OF IT. NOBODY'S
PAYING ATTENTION TO TREVOR
LAWRENCE.
I THINK HE PROBABLY LIKES IT.
HONESTLY, I DO. I MEAN THAT'S
LISTEN, I THINK
URBAN MEYER HAS A WEIRD
OBSESSION WITH TIM TEBOW AND I
ACTUALLY THINK THEY WANTED TO
MAKE THE TEAM, BUT THE THEORY
THAT THEY BROUGHT IN TIM TEBOW
TO PROVIDE A MEDIA
SHELL FOR THE REST OF THE
TEAM, ESPECIALLY THEIR
FRANCHISE QUARTERBACK.
I ACTUALLY DON'T
IF
YOU COULD TELL ME YOU COULD
CONVINCE ME OF THAT THEORY,
LET'S JUST SAY THAT.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT. I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE LOOK, IT
HASN'T PROVIDED THE MEDIA
SHELL. THEY DIDN'T MAKE THEM
AVAILABLE DURING THE OFFSEASON
PROGRAM. THEY'RE TRYING TO
DOWNPLAY
THE MEDIA ASPECT. WAIT,
IT HAS THOUGH. EVERY JAGUARS
STORY WE JUST SAID NO ONE'S
TALKING ABOUT TREVOR LAWRENCE.
EVERY JAGUAR STORY HAS BEEN
TIM TEBOW.
THAT'S A FACT.
WELL AND THERE'S STILL HAVEN'T
BEEN MANY JAGUAR STORIES.
THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM. I
MEAN IT IS AMAZING TO ME.
HOW WE HAVE IN PLAIN SIGHT.
A GRAND EXPERIMENT
OF A LIFETIME COLLEGE COACH
WHO IS BRINGING
DECIDEDLY COLLEGE FOOTBALL
WAYS TO THE NFL, LIKE
JIMMIE JOHNSON, DID 30 PLUS
YEARS AGO
AND, AND NO ONE'S REALLY
PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH JACKSONVILLE AND
WE'LL SEE WHAT THEY DO. COMING
OUT OF THE GATES. THEY WON
THEIR FIRST GAME LAST YEAR AND
THEN PROCEEDED TO LOSE ALL THE
REST OF THEM, BUT WE'LL SEE
WHAT THEY CAN DO THAT. THAT
COULD BE
A STORYLINE.
THAT TAKES OFF HOW TREVOR
LAWRENCE COULD END UP BEING AN
MVP CANDIDATE, IF THIS WORKS
IN JACKSONVILLE, BUT I THINK S